Film Courage: The difference between editing,
revising and just plain skimming your work
or a page you’ve done for the day, either
skimming it (and) praising it or skimming
it (and) unfortunately trashing it (I mean
being critical of it)?
So what are the differences between the three:
editing, revising and skimming?
Or are they all kind of the same?
Barrington Smith Seetachitt: Skimming is what
I do when I don’t know what I am going to
do.
Then you’re kind of…well okay.
So editing, revising, skimming…interesting.
I don’t know how often I ever skim.
A skim would be like a copy edit or I literally
kind of…or I’m just tired and I’m just
going to read this through and maybe…I can’t
remember was it Eric…Eric Roth, he’s a
screenwriter?
Is he the one who did (THE CURIOUS CASE OF)
BENJAMIN BUTTON?
What he talks about when he writes, he always
starts at the beginning and reads through
up to where he’s going to start writing
and then writes from there.
And of course, in the reading through there
is little things you want to change so I’ll
do that.
And then there’s editing, like copy editing
and I make tons of typos so I definitely do
that as well.
Then I give it to other people to edit and
then I edit again and it’s still a mess.
But revision, I try to approach it as a very
specific process whereby I go into it with
a plan.
I’m like okay, this is a scene and it’s
weak and the scene has these building blocks
and there is a certain beginning, middle and
end and it needs some kind of adjustment and
so I try to look within that scene at kind
of the polarity.
Like there is usually a little tiny character
arc within the scene, right?
Somebody opens the door for their date, hopeful,
and then they have a little conversation and
by the time they get to the car, they’re
feeling like “This is going to be great!”
or by the time they get to the car they’re
like “This is already a disaster” and
those are two different things.
And so a lot of times I think the revision
process is where you’ve kind of looked at
the scene in terms of tracking what the character
is going to go through throughout the entire
script.
Where does this scene fit into it?
How is it setting up for other things?
What does it need to do?
So I look at it in terms of function and in
terms of those building blocks and so when
I revise I have a very “Now it does this
and now I either want it to do this better
or I want it to do something that’s different.”
That’s my ideal revision.
You don’t always get that luxury.
Sometimes you’re just like “This sucks!
And somehow I’ve got to make it seem better.”
And then you’re just fiddling but revision
in its ideal form for me is that.
Janice Rhoshalle Littlejohn: Editing, skimming
and revision?
I think to a certain extent I agree with all
of that.
For me, when I’m writing something I do
tend to just write out, just completely and
then go back and read what I’ve written
before I go to bed or before I give it up
and see if I can go a little and do a little
of the tweaking and, even to a certain extent,
see how much further I can go until I hit
a wall and then the next morning I go back
and re-read.
I do a lot of self-editing, whether it be
for small words or how can I say this better?
Or how can it sound more real?
How can it sound more authentic?
Because I think as a journalist I write differently
than I speak and so one of the challenges
for me with dialogue has been listening to
how people speak and to the cadence to which
people speak and that’s why going to café’s
was important to me because getting the rhythm
of a particular speech pattern was important
to me.
I would listen to my friends in a different…actually…screenwriting
made me a better listener.
Because I would listen to what people were
saying and how they were saying it and what
inflections they gave it.
So when I edit am I keeping that rhythm?
Is that cadence still flowing?
So I’m looking and editing for specific
things.
And then with the revision (like what Barrington
was saying), you know, I’m looking at the
overall and what can make the overall better.
I guess the editing and skimming kind of go
hand-in-hand for me.
It’s like I’m doing that all at one time
looking for different things but I actually
like the process of editing and I’m working
as an editor now for Los Angeles Review of
Books and working on other people’s work
and looking at how to make their work better
because that was always one of the things
that I loved about my editors is that they
kept the voice that I was looking for and
my voice in the story.
But they just made it that much better.
And so that’s what editing for me is.
It’s a way to make things better.
Not always did editors make it better but
those that did, that was where I found you
know, a strength.
And keeping that voice and making sure the
best of that voice came through out.
So what I hope when I’m editing is just
honing in on those things that really make
that voice sound authentic and I think to
our credit one of the things that people said
was that each of the characters had their
own distinct voice and so that was really
gratifying and so now it’s just the revising
and making sure all that great voice is in
context with a great story and a strong sensibility
and good conflict and deep, meaningful you
know…great…deep…meaningful Barrington
Smith Seetachitt: Story!
[Laughs]
Janice Rhoshalle Littlejohn: Story…yes…that
was a word I couldn’t seem to get out [laughs].
Barrington Smith Seetachitt: And something
you said in there also made me think of kind
of you know, I think my mind tends to jump
to this kind of prose editing but I think
hearing her talk about voice, one another
kind of editing that you’ll do is you’ll
take a pass.
So you’ll do a dialogue pass, especially
if…we don’t get to do as many passes as
we like because it seems like we’re always
writing to a deadline but given the amount
of time, like you’ll do a dialogue pass,
and then you’ll do kind of a pass for geography
and a pass for certain characters.
Like you’ll do a pass where you’re just
kind of tracking where one character is emotionally.
You know, do they have a logical progression
of emotion between if you know where the beginning
is and you know where the end is or is there
some place in the middle where they are in
a scene but you’re getting kind of lost
and you can just put in a reaction that shows
that something is changing in them if they
are reacting in a certain way to what is going
on, so that it’s something that you see
on the screen more, right?
So you do your main character pass.
Sometimes you’ll do a pass for secondary
characters.
So you’ll do those kind of different passes
and I guess that would also fall under editorial.
Question for the Viewers: What thoughts on
editing a screenplay can you add?